i want to bring in my first guest she's
got a great special on hbo max called
horn dog please welcome bros
matafio rose thank you so much for for
being here and doing
thank you for having me thank you so
much are you enjoying your
two cocktails yeah i'm enjoying my mine
at once
i've got my cocktail in a mug oh look at
that discreet someone has struggled with
alcoholism before
i kill you yeah it's a mug it wasn't a
paper a bag before
um i it is eight a.m in new zealand okay
great
for a gingerbreak they say is it is it
crazy is it like
is it not okay to drink an idea and i
should be drinking i i think
in quarantine rules no it's completely
fine at any time
anytime i i drink i drink a lot
in long term let's be right
i'm getting really close to the camera i
drank a lot yeah
i lived with my um my nan i locked down
with my
70 76 year old uh grandmother
and um we we got on it we definitely got
on it we um we'd make a new cocktail
every night
we had some we had a spritz night
learned how to make
martinis we got steamed actually yeah it
was great
this is great this is good energy i'll
be doing it's a great energy
i mean i think your nan should be
hosting this i'm
talking myself out of a job here and get
her a whole bottle
of whatever she wants in a giant coffee
mug
i was watching your special and one
thing that really stood out to me
is how present you were with the crowd
during that special i feel like a lot of
times people are recording their special
like
okay i'm immortalizing my dream
everything needs to be worked perfect
and i can count at least 12 times where
you stop down and
you address whatever was happening in
that room is that something that you had
planned on before
is that a product of the festival it's
just it's very rare to see that
that's a that's yeah i never really
thought about that that's um
i think it definitely is a product of
the festival before the shows
in edinburgh oh actually all of the
shows i play uh ping pong
um like i play table tennis with the
crowd before i'd start
and it's something i just started doing
in edinburgh like i did that
for horndog and then the year before i
would go around and make labels for
everyone on my label maker
yeah and meet the crowd sneakily i think
it's a way of like reminding that crowd
that i'm a human being
and they're about to see an hour from a
real person
that wants you to love them um but
you know and it breaks down some some
type of barrier where it's like
it does break down something where it's
like this is a kind of um
an exchange rather than me just talking
at you and right i hope that comes
across
well i find so much trouble in naming
things how'd you come up with horn dog
it's kind of a happy accident it's um
yeah
it's really hard to name things i named
it because i just thought it was a
really funny
name and word it was and it came i think
that
you know when you come up with a name
and you kind of come up with the ideas
for the show
yeah that kind of happened but it's so
funny because it's like
it was genuinely one of the it was the
year that i was like i'm just gonna
choose a stupid name
and that would be funny to do like a
silly name
and then that now has become the kind of
title and
i guess word and concept that has been
incredibly
linked to my career as a stand-up um i
don't know as a reminder that stand up
is really stupid and silly
and it can be silly as as well as
you know meaningful but that those two
things are just not they're not the end
of
uh spectrum it's like it's all kind of
intertwined and so you know
uh a show called that um um
luckily winning uh quite a an amazing
award
felt very funny there's like awards now
that say horn dog on
them i don't know everybody is huge
literally i've got it i've got on this
massive um
statue and it's engraved it's it's
rosemary
horndog yeah which is just it looks like
it's calling me a horn dog which is not
completely untrue but
no no it's so prestigious you want it
for being the horniest well that's what
i did like about your special too
because i think a lot of the
festival shows can be very heavy-handed
and there's just pressure to have a
theme
there's always that cadence you can tell
when someone's trying to heavily
handedly
end the show and it's not even a smart
sentence
but what they do is they slow down the
voice
to let you know all they wrote
i can't i can't handle that it might be
my
my kind of me being from new zealand and
being so deeply self-deprecating that i
could never take myself that seriously
uh
to do that i i don't know if it's that
or just um
yeah i i the confidence it takes
to believe that like what i'm saying
is correct and important
to but i mean like but to be fair i mean
i i feel like all stand up is that so
it's kind of you know ridiculous to kind
of be like i'm not like that
but you know it's it's yeah it is a
little bit of a cop-out to just try to
get those awards or trying to make it an
award-winning
show of like you do this whole hour and
then it's nothing
just because you use that cadence that
they use at mpr
completely i think you could say
anything in that cadence and it would
still stop you could be like
milk milk lemonade
[Laughter]
fudge was made to black and everyone's
like whoa okay
wow that was huge let's put that whole
sentence on an award
i think i'm i'm i'm just lucky because i
i mean i've seen so many
so many other canadian specials and kind
of really
tried to think about what would be the
best um to represent me which turns out
it was an incredibly garish backdrop
which i was like
i was watching it and i was like geez
rose and then
the part of me was like that's exactly
you and your style of personality which
is
garish and over the top um so you know
don't lie to yourself the musical
choices too i feel like we would have
been
musical soul mates high school kentucky
keen is in there we got a cane we're
talking full out
boys oh my gosh
yeah oh my gosh i mean i've got like a i
feel like i've got a guilty
not guilty but uh a playlist of you know
very much
the fallout boys the panic at the best
goes yeah even a bit of
escape and play 2000's emo rock
where it's in hindsight it's so insane
that because i remember connected
as a kid but now it's just so weird to
realize like oh those guys were
30. those guys were 30 and like
incredibly
like deeply misogynistic it's so funny
like like um there's like that metro
station
um curse of curves who is that by
there's some like um i've been listening
to like the actual lyrics of these songs
and it's just a bunch of like
as you say legit 30 year old men talking
about how
uh like wily women are being like
they'll get you they're not the good
guys in these songs you know
and it's just like you get caught up in
the insane like we were both sixteen and
you said so
i believe in all you're not over this 16
year old girl
that's half your life again
well i i miss i miss so
much that style of singing no one has
ever read jiffy lube
i want those
[Music]
but don't you find that there is like
always an affirmation like a vocal
uh style that becomes popular like i
feel like there's that kind of indie
female singer songwriter one that's very
popular now as well
which is kind of like speaking like
you've got like a plum in your mouth
like
like it's like wide like ciao
it's very yeah one
like it's yeah it's more like a wide
kind of my increments and the voice is
cracky like uh
i didn't even try rose doing a show
at 5 00 am
oh i love it uh so the not only do you
have
an hbo max special which is a huge
accomplishment but you also have an hbo
max series
which is huge that's like every comic's
goal can you tell us a little bit about
the series no it's still in the works
yeah no it's still on the way it's um
it's it's called star struck it's a um
uh
uh hbo max and bbc got together and
gonna make this show um uh
yeah we're gonna be making it soon
um a character i play has like a one
night stand with a very famous
person and um i can't i can't lie
writing it was very writing the pilot
did feel like a
creepy fan fiction everyone keeps asking
if it's based on true events and i'm
like
i would i honestly wish no no this is
wish fulfill this is which fulfillment
is there a real celebrity that's that's
in there or is it like a
placeholder celebrity no well no we got
it we're a very very
very talented actor but um i think um i
think it probably would have hit close
to home
for like an actual big celeb
also i feel like sometimes celebs are
kind of bad at playing versions of
themselves where they have to be like
aware of
the nature of their life and job a bit
so you know it's it's good to step away
from that and kind of yeah you know
it's basically a real celebrity i can't
yeah
vote this is
julia roberts the special is called
horndog on hbo
max and then you have a show coming out
with hbo max 2 this is all very exciting
i hope to talk to you
again soon lovely to talk to you thanks
moses thank you
it's our two drink minimum presented by
hbo max
clean yes great to just spill this all
over my computer
oh my gosh all right cheers thanks rose
see ya
you